good morning labour is coming under
pressure from the unions and some mps
after shadow minister sam terry was
sacked from the front bench after he
joined railway workers on the picket
line labour says he was removed for
making unauthorized tv appearances
including this interview with us
yesterday morning here's a reminder of
what he had to say
i've not been instant normal to anyone i
support kia osama i think he's by far
the best person to be prime minister of
this country i believe he will be the
prime minister of this country my job
today is to support transport workers as
a shadow transport minister to support
the traveling public every worker
deserves a pay rise that is in line with
inflation and at the moment the rmt and
tsa have been offered four percent this
year when inflation's running at 11 and
then at 2 on the following two years
that is a real terms pay cut no worker
should be offered a pay cut as a way
forward whilst having a sort of gun put
to their head in terms of losing their
jobs
yesterday um kia stammer was watching he
didn't like what he saw john mcdonald
party's former shadow chancellor is with
us hello to you thanks for joining us on
the program what did you make of what's
happened over the last 24 hours
i don't know who's advising kirsten but
this is a completely unnecessary row
that's been invented just at a time when
the tories are tearing themselves apart
and we've got the maximum opportunity i
think to gain an advantage in the polls
that will take us build the support to
take us into a government we're having
this completely unnecessary row it's
as i said sam went on the picket lines
like
well like
minister after minister shadow minnesota
shadow minister over the years
in support of workers who are asking for
a decent pay rise it's a just cause i
mean
and now we're told he's been sacked not
because he went on the picket lines but
because he made statements on the picket
lines but what was he supposed to do go
on there wear a gag it's a it's a silly
silly situation to get into so i think
we just need to accept that there will
be a wave of industrial action now
inevitably from union after union
because their members are voting
overwhelmingly for industrial action
because they're saying we can't accept a
pay cut and we've got to come off the
fence and be on the side of well adjust
cause the workers i think they've got it
right so it's this is an unnecessary
dispute and i i regret whoever's advised
kirsten on this i think has made it a
severe mistake
um he was sacked rotel because he was
making up policy on the fly it's not for
a junior shadow minister to make up the
policy of the opposition party
well he's expressed a view about the
dispute which i think is the correct
view that's the first thing but you know
rachel reeves went on an interview last
week and made up policy on rail
nationalization which had to be
contradicted by the shadow spokesperson
on transport within hours i didn't see
rachel reeves being sacked
i just think this is an unnecessary
division when we should be united and
you know the tory leadership election is
demonstrating how the tories are ripping
themselves apart this is the time when
we should have maximum unity a maximum
solidarity for the support for our
workers who are desperate to have a
decent pay rise because they're being
impacted upon so badly by this cost of
living crisis what do you want the
leader to do he tells them not to go on
the picket lines they do anyway some of
them are disciplined and let me finish
sanctioned and then they do it again
he's told him not to and they do it
again not only does he do that as a you
know he was the most senior of of the
labour mps that was there he's all be a
junior uh shadow minister not only does
he do that he then goes on the telly
does a round of media rounds and
disagrees with the policy of the party
what do you want him to do
well
i think the advisers around here have
dug us into a hole in the first place
unnecessarily by telling people not to
go on picket lines the reality is over
the years we're a trade we were formed
by the trade unions so when the trade
unions have a just cause we support them
and this is a just cause people have
been impacted upon by the cost of living
crisis they don't want a wage cut
they're trying to negotiate but they're
being forced to take industrial action
so you back them that's what we did in
the p o dispute you know the labor party
came out in favor of the workers there
because it was a just cause now to dig
ourselves into a hole like this telling
people they can't go on picket lines was
inevitably going to lead to something
like this a a real mistaken division
like this i think it's time to back off
and recognize the real issue is what
working-class people are going through
at the moment which is a terrible cost
of living crisis how do we solve it we
back them by getting inflation approved
pay awards to support them it's as
simple as that so i i think mistakes
have been made from the very beginning
we need to stand back and actually start
trying to secure unity across not just
the whole labor and trade union movement
but across the country overall i think
kia and his advisors have completely
misread the situation i think they've
misread the mood within the labor and
trade union movement but i also think
they've misread the mood amongst the
general public who also there's millions
of people out there who are now
contemplating and voting for industrial
action because they can't survive on the
wages and the wage offer that they've
been given so we've got to back them
because it's the just cause okay so what
would you say to those that suggest that
actually what he's trying to do is make
the party electable which is what you
and jeremy corbyn didn't manage to do
well
because what we're trying to do now is
make the party electable and one way of
making it electable is making sure you
secure the support of those millions of
people out there who like us think
actually it's wrong to impose a wage cut
on people when there's a cost of living
crisis like this and what we're doing
now is alienating people when the
election comes you know people will
rightfully say where were you when we
needed you when we were campaigning to
prevent our wages being cut that's all
that this is about i actually i do think
they've misread the public mood i've
certainly misread the mood within the
labour and trade union i've never seen
this level of anger but also you know
this level of solidarity wave after wave
of trade unions now are balloting
they're getting overwhelming results
people turning out in large numbers and
90 voted for industrial action we've
never seen that before why because
people are pretty angry and they're
saying we can't live on these wages well
they were given the opportunity of
course weren't they um back in 2019 mr
mcdonald and you presided over with
jeremy corbyn the biggest loss for
labour since 1935 but as you learned
those lessons it was a brexit general
election simple as that we've moved on
since then and the issues that people
are facing now are
tough it's a tough economic environment
out there where people have had 12 years
of
pay freezes and pay pay cuts they're now
hit with inflation going up to 11
and some of them are being offered two
or three percent wage increases which
means a wage cut times have moved on
since december 19 what we have to
recognize is that people are suffering
out there and we've got to be seen to be
on their side and one way of being seen
to be on their side is when they take
industrial action you support them you
join the picket lines and you back them
up it's a basic principle of solidarity
not just in the labor and trade union
boom but actually i think it's at the
heart of our society as well where you
support people when they've got a just
pause
rmt union chief mick lynch yesterday on
the program calling for a general strike
would you support him in that
well what's happening now what's
interesting if you look at the ballots
that are taking place across the trade
junior movement we talk about millions
of workers now voting for industrial
action so naturally what people are
saying is well why not coordinate that
well i support coordinated action
because if that results then you know
decent pay rise for people they're
protected against the cost of living
crisis i think that's the most effective
thing to do but you know this is
completely unnecessary what it needs is
the government to recognize that you
can't expect people to ex to have a well
to stand on one side when their wages
are being cut you know it's tough out
there people are struggling to survive
keep up with
their rents their mortgages putting food
on the table for their children we can't
go on like this we've got to protect
people and that's why people are saying
well we're going to have to take
industrial action and if that means
coordinated action to make it more
effective and to resolve the disputes
that's much more quickly more so be it
so you would support circle for a
general strike we haven't had one of
those since 1928.
well i don't i don't think it would be
necessary if we had a government that
recognized just how tough it is for
people out there you can't expect people
to have a pay cut when prices are going
up so well 11 and you know for some
people that's even higher so you can
understand why people are angry you can
understand why they vote for industrial
action and you can understand why unions
are saying if we are going to strike we
might as well coordinate that action so
coordinated action i think is going to
be inevitable and i just hope the
government starts listening
if there are picket lines that are
caused as a result of that i think the
role of the labour mp is to be on those
picket lines and that's what i've been
doing because it's a
it's a just cause and i support working
people when they're suffering in this
way the resolution of it is in the hands
of the government just protect people
against this cost of living crisis
yeah the last time we had coordinated
action it wasn't a general strike but
coordinated action amongst unions was uh
1978-79
and i'm sure it was a labor government
that was in power then
well
that's exactly the point i'm trying to
make really okay
i'm not getting it if you are go on try
again if it's the just cause
what you have to do is support the cause
if you think it's the right thing to do
it doesn't really matter who's in
government you have to ensure that you
do the right thing and the right thing
at the moment is to recognize that
working class people are suffering at
the moment to have a government then
imposing a pay cut on them when there's
a cost of living crisis like this is
completely wrong and therefore people
reacting against it and they're using
what method is left open to them which
is to withdraw their labor to go on
strike so therefore if it's a just cause
you support them and in that way you can
resolve the disputes you can make sure
people get a decent pay rise and you
help them through this cost of living
crisis okay people cannot ask them for
the earth you know they're just asking
to help us get through this coming
crisis okay